desde hace 21 años eric adelante en el
jardín de niños y estancia infantil un
mundo del nuevo milenio y en los últimos
seis meses lo que ha construido está a
punto de venirse abajo pues los papás de
80% de los niños no pueden pagar ya las
cuotas y se han ido con lo que pasó de
la pandemia
estella me es muy difícil traer a mi
hija por falta de recursos el panorama
para hídricas es incierto esta situación
de la pandemia vino a afectarnos se
podría decir a un 100 por ciento estamos
tomando la decisión de probablemente
cerrar para el próximo mes por la falta
de niños en méxico hay 40.000 escuelas
privadas de todos los niveles y cerca de
15.000 de ellas especialmente de
primaria y secundaria enfrentan
dificultades y cuando pase el periodo de
inscripciones se verá cuántas habrán
tenido que cerrar los estudiantes que se
están saliendo en términos generales va
a ser alrededor de más de un millón y
medio de estudiantes que han estado
desertando de las escuelas particulares
se están yendo a las escuelas oficiales
las autoridades aseguran que tienen
capacidad
para enfrentar esta realidad esa
migración que se debe de escuelas
privadas de forma natural por la
condición económica en méxico tenemos
200 mil escuelas en básica en el país y
un millón doscientos mil maestros de
manera que están preparados para recibir
esta migración el sub-secretario es
optimista no así las madres que no
tendrán quien les cuida a sus hijos si
cierran las estancias privadas por la
crisis
mi hija come desayuna aquí todos los
días de lunes a viernes
y el que lo cierre me afecta demasiado
porque yo trabajo trabajo y yo no tengo
el tiempo para poder estar con ella en
las tardes además de dueños de escuelas
padres y alumnos otros afectados son los
maestros pues según la asociación de
escuelas particulares unos 200.000
trabajadores del sector educativo
podrían quedarse sin trabajo